right with more than two-thirds of the
vote counted republican glenn younkin
now has a clear advantage in the
virginia gubernatorial race fox news
projects now that mcauliffe needs to win
roughly two-thirds of the outstanding
vote to change that outcome it's a
pretty tall order and the fox news
decision desk is not yet ready to make a
projection but again young youngkin has
a very clear and decisive advantage at
this moment
tonight
the seismic event that is this virginia
governor's race
we have reporters on the ground and full
election analysis from some of the best
political thinkers in the country
throughout this hour
and you've been hearing me talk about
this now for a better part of the last
year
by all accounts glenn younkin has
outperformed in counties from deep blue
suburban northern virginia to the rural
southwest
and it's very important to remember
everyone has to remember this that
few really thought that this would have
been possible just one year ago
but in nine and a half short months
corn pop's buddy has laid waste to the
democrats dream of a post-trump
political nirvana
we virginians have watched in horror as
biden has destroyed almost every
advantage americans have over other
citizens of other countries
our energy independence our workforce
our unity our border our military's
prestige
and then they saw another relic of the
past terry mcauliffe promised more of
the same
adding fuel to the fire the cynical and
rabid anti-americanism that has infected
our schools
an errand boy for the teachers union
mcauliffe saw nothing wrong with loudoun
county
all a big to do about nothing
a close race in a state that trump lost
by 10 that hasn't elected a republican
governor for 12 years would have still
been good news for the gop
but an outright win for yunkan is 9.8 on
the richter scale
with far left policies buried in the
rubble
now this night would not have been
possible without the man determined to
prove the critics wrong
glenn younkin himself
he's one of the hardest candidates
hardest working candidates we've ever
seen
he wasn't afraid to campaign in liberal
northern virginia he wasn't afraid to
take on the school boards and the
radicals that are running our once great
education system into the ground
he wasn't afraid to stand up for gun
rights for sane economic policies
and yes for american history
most people who are attacked savagely by
the media machine fold they melt
trump didn't
and glenn younkin didn't either
he just kept pushing
remember how democrats felt election
night a year ago they were triumphant
they were elated
braggarts they were seemingly
unstoppable
of course republicans
man demoralized
angry oh yeah angry despondent
many of you turned off your tvs for
months
well how are you feeling now
you should feel really hopeful and
optimistic
junkin was right this is a common sense
movement run by normal average people
who want a better life for themselves
and their families we love this country
a country which is not systematically
racist by the way and we're sick of
seeing people canceled or threatened or
intimidated or shamed for speaking their
minds or saying no to a vaccine
and by the looks of things on the other
networks they're taking all the wrong
lessons from this race
i think that the the real ominous thing
is that
critical race theory
which isn't real
turned the suburbs
15 points
to the trump insurrection endorsed
republican have we seen the emergence of
the delta variant of trumpism
the delta variant of trumpism in other
words younkin
same disease but spreads a lot faster it
can get a lot more places
remember when van jones was the big
uniter he was kind of a moderate reach
across the aisle that's out the window
well last year democrats had so many
forces going their way they had the
covered panic they had the blm hysteric
hysteria they had the vicious anti-trump
fervor
but tonight shows us that trump's
policies were in fact very popular
because they actually work
in retrospect it may be that 2020 was
not the beginning for the democratic
left
but it's zenith
they misread the electorate and badly
america is back hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else